monsieur le président de la république
française jeudi française parce que
n'oublions jamais que nous sommes le
pays la révolution
celui qui aboutit les cas supprimer les
privilèges et celui des droits de
l'homme
je m'appelle francis courel je suis
maire de saint philbert sur hull dix
villages de la vallée où le président
coty qui habitait le havre venait pêcher
de temps en temps sur le radier aclu et
je suis conseiller départemental de
pont-audemer
je vais vous faire une confidence à
chaque fois que je vais me recueillir
sur la tombe de mon père sans être
particulièrement croyant je lui parle
pourquoi mon père a fait deux mois et
demi de grève en 1936 pour obtenir les
premiers quinze jours de congés payés la
semaine de 40 heures et les premières
conventions collectives et avant qu'il
disparaisse
je lui ai promis de continuer son combat
ensuite pour détendre l'atmosphère
je vous informe que sur le territoire de
ma commune
l'usiné nestlé petfood fabrique des
croquettes pour animaux
le célèbre proplan qui plaît beaucoup au
labrador griffon
et si nemo en mange
eh bien elle sera protégée de
l'intérieur et portera toujours un poil
brillant
[Applaudissements]
vendredi dernier l'ong janvier depuis
qu'ils sont exclus des ronds points
j'ai réuni 400 gilet jaune en assemblée
populaire venu de beuzeville brille un
neuneu bourg conteuse mer certains même
de l'orne
accompagné d'une personne docteur en
psychologie clinique de l'université de
québec
spécialiste de l'intelligence collective
qui m'a aidé à coacher la réunion mon
objectif était clair donner la parole au
peuple des ronds-points canaliser les
colères traduire les émotions et
souffrance par des revendications
légitimes continuer à échanger pour
retrouver de la dignité et de la
citoyenneté
la sociologie ce groupe kohl est à peu
près avec la typologie nationale des
ronds points
ah bon paquet d'employés ouvriers actifs
des retraités des jeunes des artisans
commerçants responsables de pme des
agriculteurs des chômeurs et une
présence forte de femmes qui à la maison
tiennent les cordons de la bourse
s'occupe des enfants et demeure très
inquiètes pour leur avenir
rien à voir avec les agitateurs révolter
ou les casseurs de policiers j'ai plutôt
constaté avec satisfaction comme une
sorte de réveil démocratique en marche
qui interpelle un système probablement à
bout de souffle
le groupe n'a eu aucune difficulté à
dire que l'appauvrissement des classes
populaires les classes moyennes et le
recul de l'état en tant que puissance
capable de rééquilibrer les inégalités
ne vais pas être une fatalité
celle qui provoque la
désindustrialisation des territoires et
la concentration des richesses du côté
des gagnants du système
les multinationales et les milliardaires
qui souvent échappent à l'impôt j'en
viens donc aux observations formulées
sur le seul sujet de la fiscalité
parmi tant d'autres car à côté de
l'urgence l'augmentation des salaires
l'injustice fiscale aujourd'hui est un
socle commun
je le président en supprimant lisf
mobilières vous avez fait un cadeau d'un
million au sens français les plus riches
dans la discussion la tva qui représente
50 % des recettes nationales
il a été dit qu'elle devrait s'appliquer
avec des taux différenciés abaissé celui
sur les produits de première nécessité
peint les viandes poissons j'en passe et
des meilleurs croquettes côté augmenté
sur les produits de luxe
le taux sur les produits de luxe l'impôt
sur le revenu lui appliquer une
indispensable progressivité
monsieur le responsable de bercy
pourquoi ne pas passer de cinq à
quatorze tranches
pourquoi ne pas prélever à la source et
l'appliquer rapidement prélevé à la
source les dividendes